destination North Pole the North Pole
check out this newspaper article from
1913 hope to solve Earth's final puzzle
icy Crocker Island and then you see this
map of like the North Pole and right
next to it the theoretical location of
crockerland a lost continent that was
supposed to be right next to the North
Pole this is the early 1900s it's a time
when the world map has been thoroughly
explored and documented there were just
a few places that were still kind of
blank and this was one of them High
North an icy ocean that was incredibly
difficult to get through but people
thought there was this North Polar
continent unexplored for now but people
wanted to get in on it they wanted to
see what was up here and in fact a
couple explorers roaming around this
area had reported seeing land up here it
created this frenzy this Wonder was
there a lost polar continent up near the
North Pole I want to show you the story
of how this all went down it's the story
of the explorers who decided to go into
the most impossible terrain on Earth
just to explore it and it led to a
passionate rivalry between these two
dudes with big egos it's full of fake
photos and smear campaigns and it was
kind of like the space race of the day a
race to see who could be the first to
get to the top of the world
[Music]
okay so let's get up to speed on what
we're talking about here the Arctic is
kind of anything above this line but we
should ditch this map this is the
Mercator Projection which I kind of have
thoughts on where the Mercator fails is
its representation of size it massively
distorts everything in the north and
south and it's just not going to be good
for this story so we need a better map
check out this map this one's way better
watch
this beautiful map I have had for a very
long time and I'm finally going to be
able to use it for a story
look at that beauty
[Music]
man this is just such a beautiful map
just gorgeous this is what we're going
to use to tell the story this is the top
of the world but anyway before we go on
I need to say thank you to today's
sponsor
um who made today's video possible thank
you better help for sponsoring today's
video I've said it before and I'm going
to continue to say it I'm a massive fan
of therapy I believe that therapy has
been stigmatized over the years and
we're going through an era where it's
finally being normalized I've been in
therapy for a few years now it's changed
my life and one thing I know is that
finding a therapist is really hard like
it's a often very clunky process of like
calling doctor's offices and checking
insurance and all this stuff better help
is a platform that solves this with
better help you just take a quiz and
then it pairs you up with a therapist in
their giant network of like tens of
thousands of licensed therapists that
aren't confined to your geographic
location and you can communicate how you
want either through text message or a
phone call or a video chat you get to
choose how you communicate with your
therapist if your therapist isn't a good
fit you can change for free which if
you've ever done traditional therapy
before that's much more difficult of a
process you can message your therapist
at any time and schedule live sessions
when it is convenient for you all of
this allows therapy to be more
accessible more affordable and there's
even financial aid for those who need it
so there's a link in my description it
is betterhelp.com Johnny Harris clicking
that link helps support this channel it
also gets you 10 off your first month of
better help so you can try it out at a
discount and hopefully see if it's a
good fit for you thank you better help
for sponsoring this video Let's dive
into this insane story about the North
Pole
[Music]
top of the world reminder that this is
just one giant ocean but the reason it
looks like this is because it's frozen
you can't just like sail through it and
yet many explorers had this lofty goal
they wanted to reach the North Pole the
arbitrary place on our planet that's
just a bunch of ice sheets sliding
around where all the longitude lines
come together the place that we just
decided with math was the top of the
earth you know the North Pole where
Santa lives that's what we're talking
about that is what the Explorers wanted
to like get to so why attempt to reach
an arbitrary bit of ocean that's super
impractical and risky because it's there
dummy we're humans we don't ask
questions like that we just have to go
people have been trying to get up here
for centuries trying to figure out what
they would find maybe if they got
through the ice there would be some warm
water ocean here maybe there'd be new
shipping routes over the top of the
globe by 1845 explorers were making
custom ships they were reinforcing the
hulls of Warships with thicker wood that
could take on the pressure of the ice
and they would go and explore and they
didn't find any useful shipping routes
but they did find people these people
the Inuit knew a thing or two about how
to handle the cold they knew how to
build shelters out in the ice they made
kayaks and parkas they used dog sledges
to get around oh and these dog sledges
are pretty cool
but let's not get distracted that's for
a totally different story that I'm doing
on Greenland the point is that these
American and European explorers realize
that any North Pole Expedition with a
Chance of success would need to rely on
Inuit guides so it's the late 1870s and
we start to see the first serious
attempts to finally reach the North Pole
every attempt being its own version of
crazy let me show you some of these all
of these little lines are different
explorers and their attempt to get here
to the center to the North Pole and each
one was insane like this guy who
intentionally floated from Russia got
his boat stuck in the ice on purpose and
then let the ice which is always moving
around sort of drift him around and
carry him with the hopes that it would
like carry him to the North Pole but
instead he just did these like sort of
loop-de-loops and eventually got like
spit out next to svalbard I mean these
guys were climbing like 30-foot ice
ridges they were facing off with polar
bears whose territory this is I mean
these guys are out exploring in some of
the harshest conditions ever in the name
of
Adventure exploration like that is why
they were doing this they became Heroes
for kids back home but anyway this is
all just backstory our story that I
really want to tell you about starts now
and it has to do with this guy Robert
Peary
Arctic explorer who is obsessed with
getting to the North Pole I mean just
look at Robert peary's portrait
Perry was an American Navy engineer who
was dead set on becoming famous once
writing a letter to his mother saying
quote remember mother I must have Fame
like that's who this guy is he and his
obsession with being famous is a huge
part of this story
so Perry is out exploring the Arctic he
makes Greenland his hopping off point
that's sort of his home base and on his
second Expedition he breaks his leg
luckily in his expedition he's got this
greeny doctor who comes and helps mend
his leg and while his leg was healing
they stayed up in the Arctic for like
six months and during that time this
greeny doctor Frederick Cook learns a
bunch of skills for surviving in the
Arctic he even starts picking up the
Inuit language okay So eventually
Perry's leg heals and they head back
down south and Perry is like pretty
impressed with the greeny Doctor Who's
now learned all these new skills he's
like wow cook you're incredible we'd
love to have you on our next mission
here in the Arctic but cook wasn't into
it he didn't want to be some footnote in
history he he was feeling confident
after his one Expedition and he decided
to strike out on his own as an Explorer
period was kind of like okay cool cook
like have fun trying to be an Explorer
you're like super ungrateful for
everything I've taught you like good
luck and thus the seeds of tension were
planted between these two old school
puree versus newbie starry-eyed cook
both with big Egos and both willing to
do what it takes to show that they were
great Explorers so they go their
separate ways the Newbie doctor turned
aspiring Explorer Frederick Cook sets
out on his own expedition back to the
Arctic feeling super confident wait no
this trip doesn't get any Adventure
music it was a total failure like they
barely made it to here and then they had
to like turn back and abandon their ship
and like ah cook and Pirie is like
loving this while cook was getting owned
in the Arctic Peery continues to kill it
as this engineer turned Arctic explorer
who Pines to be famous he's busy going
to Greenland and bringing three giant
meteorites who goes out on an expedition
and comes back with meteorites like from
space
you're the real deal
he writes a book about his adventures
and starts to get heralded as the
greatest Arctic Adventurer of their day
I mean look at this face this guy's kind
of a badass true story I was in
Greenland a few weeks ago and
I tried to take a photo just like this
it didn't really work out
okay so back to cook he doesn't give up
he's slowly getting better at this whole
explore the Arctic thing he goes south
to Antarctica and goes on another
Expedition that goes horribly wrong but
this time cook is ready he meets The
Challenge and he makes it out alive
leveling up immensely in the process
by 1898 Perry moves to Greenland like
kind of permanently and makes his focus
on getting to the North Pole like that
is his dream he is training he's
recruiting people and he starts to go
out on attempts he wants to be the first
person to the top of the world
and this is where we kind of start to
see pirie's true colors like as much of
a badass as this guy is
you do a little bit of research and you
realize that he's actually kind of an
and like there's so much to say
about this but little sampler here he
brings back six Inuit to New York four
of them end up dying and there's this
whole insane story that you can read
about in the citations but yeah he's not
a great guy he cheats on his wife with a
14 year old and has a kid with her and
then there's this guy his number two
Matt Henson Henson was like one of the
best non-inuit dog sled drivers in the
world he even learned to speak the Inuit
language something that Pirie wasn't
even able to do but Pirie described him
as quote his assistant because he's
black and goes on to give him basically
no credit for all of his achievements so
yeah peer is kind of an but that
doesn't mean that he wasn't also an
incredibly skilled determined Explorer I
mean he stays up here for four years
refining his technique to get to the
North Pole he obsesses over gear and
Designs custom sledges and even creates
this like perfect water boiler and he
keeps going back making attempt after
attempt and each time some disaster
occurs they have to turn back in the
process he loses eight toes to frostbite
he keeps going he gets closer and closer
and finally decides that it is his time
so he builds this custom ship he mounts
a massive Expedition and he goes out and
on what he hopes is his last Expedition
he claims to have passed by a piece of
land sticking out of the ice this would
later go on to fuel the idea that there
is a continent up here all these
newspaper articles I was showing you
about like is there a continent near the
North Pole but anyway on this Expedition
he still doesn't make it the furthest he
was able to get was here just 200 miles
from the North Pole but he had to turn
back so wait is that it is Perry giving
up he lost eight toes to frostbite and
he didn't make it to the North Pole wait
just pause on Pirie for a second we'll
talk about what happens next but first
we got to get back to this guy cook
what's cook up to well it turns out that
cook continued to level up getting more
and more experience getting more and
more famous he goes to Alaska trying to
be the first to Summit Denali which is
the highest peak in North America and he
comes off the mountain saying that he
made it to the top whoa cook we're no
longer playing in the minor leagues he's
a legit Explorer now he's even elected
as the president of the Explorers Club
in New York by 1906 he's kind of like a
BFD in the Explorer scene and soon he's
sitting in the bougie National
Geographic Society dinner in Washington
DC a dinner that was put on to actually
honor Peery for all of his Arctic
Explorations okay so this is where it
gets juicy and like the tension drama
really starts to like rise because
during this dinner Alexander Graham Bell
the guy who invented the telephone no
big deal he gets up and is like yeah
yeah yeah Perry's cool and all I know
we're like celebrating him here in this
dinner but what about cook let's hear
from cook a man who's gone to the top
and the bottom of the earth and the
largest peak in America so Cook gets up
and toots his own horn at this dinner
that was supposed to be for perry perry
must have been pissed at this moment
like this was his moment to shine he's
getting all this attention and who's
there cook the guy was like a grainy
Doctor Who's now his rival but who Perry
considers as a hack like not a real
Explorer but now cook is feeling good
he's no longer a newbie so he sets his
sight on beating Peery to the North Pole
the race is now on
so it's 1907 and cook heads to the
Arctic he gathers a crew to go to the
North Pole there's one other Westerner
got nine Inuits and a dog sledge team
for each Peri was pissed at cook at this
moment for even attempting to be the
first one to the North Pole and to make
things worse cook was using a bunch of
puri's techniques and recruiting Inuit
that Perry had built relationships with
and doing this all just as Peri was
about to head off on a final attempt of
his own so months go by six months and
then eight months and now it's been a
year and no one has heard from cook is
he dead who cares says Puri he's getting
ready for his own expedition to the
north Teddy Roosevelt wishing him well
on his way and just like that Perry and
his crew are off racing to the North
Pole cook still out there somewhere and
the world wondering who will get there
first newspapers start wondering does he
still live
it is a seesaw of doubt and hope who may
have the story of finding the North Pole
or who may be buried somewhere in the
snow and ice and headlines back then
were so cool
and then on September 1st 1909
on this little island in the north a
ragged Dr Cook appears ashore he heads
straight to the telegraph station and
sends this message
[Music]
this is huge news crook says he reached
the North Pole and that he found land up
here in what a lot of people thought was
just a frozen ocean okay but wait it's
not over literally five days later who
shows up on the labrador Coast but
freaking Perry what
five days later he sends his own
Telegram
and if the Press wasn't already stoked
enough about cook having come back and
discovered land and got to the North
Pole first now they're going berserk
this is so juicy the great rivalry
climaxing in this big fight they can't
where you could like make this stuff up
so they turned to Peery and they're like
oh cook arrived five days ago and said
that he was the first one to get to the
North Pole before you did what he did
not just get busted by the cocky newbie
that he trained no cook is lying Perry
says the Rivalry between these two guys
is hitting a crescendo and the
newspapers they're cartoonists and their
readers are all loving it it leads to
this waterfall of memes depicting the
Rivalry which at this point was about
ego fame money reputation all playing
out in the Epic Arctic the Last Frontier
I mean this should be like a mini series
on Hulu like I would watch the hell out
of this the true story of two very
different men in pursuit of the same my
favorite cartoon is this one it's a puck
cover showing the North Pole holding a
bag of money with cook holding a note
saying I saw you first and Peri holding
a note saying so did I
oh it's so good oh oh and cook was super
into like gumdrops apparently
anyway so now it's like full-blown
information Warfare between these two
Perry's going out on this like smear
campaign to undermine Cook's credibility
saying that he's been lying about all of
his accomplishments he didn't actually
Summit Denali says Peery so then cook
fires back revealing kind of his snarky
side reminding the world that Pirie is
this 52 year old man with just two toes
oh and it's awfully suspicious that he
didn't take anyone with him who could
corroborate the latitude that he was at
among all these memes and selling of
newspapers and the public bickering the
questions still remain who actually got
there first well shouldn't that be easy
why don't we just go to the North Pole
we can obviously go there now and see
what flag is planted there no because
remember the North Pole is just a frozen
ocean and the ice drifts like miles per
day so that won't work the only way to
actually prove who got there first is to
review the evidence from these
Expeditions the journals and the records
that these guys kept and then compare
that against solitary and to be honest
both these guys accounts are full of
weaknesses and weird stuff like remember
when Peri insisted that there was a land
mass up here well a later Expedition
went out and had this like horrendous
experience of trying to look for that
land and they discovered that it was not
there that this was totally made up many
think that Perry made this up in earlier
expedition to Rally excitement to raise
money for future trips so what did that
mean who actually got there first was
everyone just lying about everything has
the North Pole ever been discovered well
it would actually be Decades of
exploration observation and Analysis
before some clear conclusions started to
emerge for this story we read through
books written by Scholars who have
dedicated much of their professional
lives to answering this question and
here's what we can finally say with some
clarity Peery probably made it to the
North Pole on this trip academics have
debated this and most say that he came
between making it like within a hundred
miles to actually making it dead center
to the north full just depending on who
you ask and while we're at it it's also
possible that Henson remember Henson the
number two who didn't get any credit
because period was probably racist was
actually the first to get there because
he was the guy who forged the path for
period of follow meaning it was very
possible that the first person to step
foot on the North Pole was a black man
kind of cool okay but what about cook
didn't he start his journey like almost
a year before Peri did he actually get
there first
no cook did not get there first years of
research has revealed that cook was a
liar like a full-blown liar the furthest
that he probably made it was like here
400 miles off of the North Pole AKA he
never actually traversed the really
difficult portion in all of this he made
it far enough to be able to tell a
convincing story and then he headed back
and sent this telegram saying that he
made it there first whoa cook okay but
at least he's like a legit Explorer
right like he summoned Denali first I
mean he had picks wait no turns out
these picks are not the top of Denali
they're actually shots from like 15
000 feet Further Down AKA not even the
elevation of Denver Colorado like this
was a total staged photo that he lied to
the world about to say that he was the
first one to make it to the tallest peak
in North America Coke was a liar he had
tricked the world and many believed him
wow
okay
so Peri was in this whole set on being
famous but at least he was a legit
explorer who probably made it to the
North Pole or close to it first and cook
seemingly a decent explorer was actually
just a much better Storyteller and a
full-blown liar
but this is kind of unsatisfying because
we don't actually know definitively who
was the first person to like touch their
foot on the North Pole which is like why
do we even need to know that why is that
important because it is no one gets the
credit without needing to go into all of
these caveats and there's way more
caveats than I've gone into here instead
this is a story of reputation
manipulation and media blitzes of
controversy and debate Optics and lying
and instead of seeing a Neil Armstrong
we're left with more of like a couple of
Elon Musk types but I won't leave you
there let's just say definitively who
made it to the North Pole first with no
asterisks
in 1926 rolled amundsen the man who had
previously won the race to the South
Pole became the first to get to the
North Pole Undisputed by flying over it
so he didn't actually touch the ice he
just flew over but it wasn't until 1948
that a Russian was the first verified
person to walk on the pole like to
actually put your boot on the North Pole
he took a plane to get there and then
just like walked on the North Pole in
1958 the USS Nautilus the world's first
nucleopard submarine went under the pole
which was another first and submarines
are really awesome and we made a whole
video about them that you should watch
then finally the first Undisputed person
to reach the North Pole by land was a
guy from Minnesota it was essentially
the culmination of like a bar bet that
got way out of hand that's a whole other
story but yeah it was 1960 eight and
with a snowmobile so it really gives you
an appreciation of what Perry was
capable of doing decades earlier using
Inuit wisdom his own clever inventions
and a lot of sled dogs
foreign
[Music]
so today the question of who got to the
North Pole first is not really a
question that most people are thinking
about a lot when it comes to the Arctic
I went to Greenland a few weeks ago and
have been reporting on the changing
Arctic exploring how different countries
are vying for ownership and influence in
this space because this frozen ocean
won't be frozen for long and now it's
opening up to new shipping routes new
resources unlocked as the ice melts but
one thing that hasn't changed is how the
media treats a story like this a race a
rivalry a public gossip fest with big
egos hungry for attention and especially
when there's imagery to go along with it
I think we're all eager to believe what
we see when it fulfills some deep need
to witness the excitement of exploration
and today the people who still want to
be in the spotlight do so by bickering
and boasting about how great they are
and the media still gleefully covers it
all covering the lies covering the
deception as long as there's a great
story and a great image to go along with
it and sometimes that's fact checked and
the truth comes out and sometimes we
just never know
foreign
[Music]
wasn't this a nuts story like isn't it
just wild these two characters and how
it's like not that much different from
like people on Twitter today anyway
um this was another Deep dive where we
had so much stuff and if you look at the
info dock which is like our kind of
research DOC for this it's literally
hundreds of pages long
so anyway uh thanks for watching I hope
this was a fun one for you and yes this
map is permanently just up in my studio
because I want to look at it every day
of my life
speaking of maps
let me show you something
I made a poster about maps and I'm very
very excited about it it is called all
maps are wrong and it is a display of a
bunch of map projections basically the
mathematical algorithms that we use to
take a spherical thing called the Earth
and put it onto a flat thing called a
piece of paper this map kind of
celebrates that it has a little
explainer in the middle that explains
why we need to do this and then it has a
name of all of the map projections that
are displayed on this poster this is
beautiful and cool and fun and I've been
wanting to design something like this
for years
but it's also a way that you can help
support what we're doing here we're
trying to make rigorous journalism on
YouTube uh not as a part of like a big
corporate entity but just like us and to
do that we more and more rely on our
community to help us do it better and to
be able to pour ourselves into these
stories and we kind of have a big team
that helps us do this now like our team
is growing in fact speaking of our team
we publish an extra video every month
that introduces you to the behind the
scenes of what we do here it is an intro
to our team to all of the people and the
processes and the shenanigans of running
the studio that is available to people
who are members of The Newsroom which is
just what we call our patreon The
Newsroom is a place that supports us but
also gets you this extra video every
month it gets you access to scripts you
get royalty-free music that you can use
and it's just a fun Community I like
post things there like like I ask for
help on thumbnails and titles I get
feedback every once I do a q a a with
the community so that is patreon.com
Johnny Harris we have lots and presets
that we use to color our videos and
photos we're publishing more courses
over at brighttrip which is the travel
startup that we started a few years ago
and is growing
um I think that's it so thank you all
for being here thanks for watching this
video we've got a lot more coming and
I'll see you in the next one
bye what
and go get your poster
and go get your poster should I
reference Greenland I should I'd be like
I was I just was up here like I can't
not be like by the way like you know
really
we have all this footage can I not be
like
keep me honest with Perry
[Music]